eight million at 888
684 dollars that's how much the United
States highest paid government employee
earns can you guess who this might be
most people's first guess is usually
government leaders maybe the president
well the US president actually only
earned 400 000 per year maybe Supreme
Court Justices well these guys only earn
just over 200 000 on average okay what
about Jerome Powell he literally prints
the money so he should earn a lot right
well even Jerome Powell only earns just
over two hundred thousand dollars per
year now don't get me wrong here these
aren't the terrible salaries by any
means but when you consider how much
work it takes to get to these positions
it doesn't seem all that lucrative if
you're a Supreme Court Justice For
example you're literally a one in nine
but you don't even earn as much as a
junior software engineer at Facebook but
wait a minute who's the government
employee who is earning 8.8 million then
well it's not leaders or chairman or
even politicians it's actually the
football coach at the University of
Alabama Nick Saban in fact it's not just
Nick who tops the government salaries
list either the top 10 government
salaries all go to football coaches at
various public universities while this
may be surprising at first glance when
you consider how much revenue a good
football coach can bring in their
compensations start to make sense but
this doesn't explain why regular
government salaries are so garbage for
example Jerome Powell is literally
responsible for printing it trillions of
dollars and inciding at macro economic
changes so you would think that this job
would be highly compensated to attract
the absolute best talent yet it's not
you don't even have to look that high up
in the ladder to realize how underpaid a
government employees are police officers
for example risk their lives to keep all
of us safe yet we're paid it seventy
thousand similarly teachers are
responsible for educating the Next
Generation yet they're paid at 55 000.
by far the worst one however is EMTs who
are directly responsible for saving it
millions of lives yet they're only paid
at 36 000. so how did government
salaries get so bad
one of the first explanations that pop
up is that government organizations are
underfunded and that this is why
government employees are underpaid but
you don't have to do much analysis to
recognize that this is completely false
federal government spending currently
clocks in at just under six trillion
dollars and the US currently has a total
of a 1.87 million federal employees this
means that the revenue per employee
clocks in at a whopping 3.2 million
dollars per employee for perspective
Apple stands at 1.9 million Facebook
stands at 1.6 million and alphabet
stands at 1.3 million and these
companies are known as the highest
paying Employers in the entire world
Apple's salary numbers are skewed due to
their retail employees but Facebook and
Google come in with median salaries of
just under 300 000 conversely the
federal government pulls in twice as
much revenue per employee as these
companies yet the average salary is only
7 39 000 people often criticize private
companies for not paying their employees
enough money but the average business
actually pays out between fifteen and
thirty percent of their revenue as
salaries the federal government on the
other hand it pays out less than a two
and a half percent of their revenue as
salaries yeah it's that bad if the
government matched the average business
and paid out fifteen to thirty percent
we would see average salaries between
480 000 and a nine hundred and sixty
thousand dollars even if they only paid
out ten percent we would see an average
salary of a 320 000 easily blowing out
the private industry but if that's the
case where is all the money going well
the answer is that it's getting stuck up
across inefficient government structures
in many aspects the government operates
as more of a charity than a logical
business take a NASA for example you may
have heard about their new SLS rocket
well it's definitely an impressive
rocket it's grossly expensive at coming
in at 4.1 at billion dollars per launch
and it's not even reusable one of the
main reasons for this is that NASA is
leveraging space shuttle technology from
the 1970s instead of the latest and the
greatest why you ask well it ends to
protect all of the industries and the
jobs that were dependent on the space
shuttle program while this is indeed a
nice sentiment it's not really all that
practical and that this is precisely why
private companies have been putting NASA
to shame the SpaceX Falcon 9 for example
only cost 67 million dollars per launch
while the Falcon heavier only costs 97
million per launch also that's how much
SpaceX is charging customers so their
internal costs are likely even lower and
in terms of payload the Falcon heavier
has a Leo pillar capacity of 64 metric
tons while SLS has a Leo payload
capacity of 70 metric tons so SLS
basically has 10 extra payload capacity
for 42 times the cost as you can see the
the government doesn't have a funding
issue what they have is an ineffective
spending issue
we can't just lay all the blame on the
government though as much of the low
salaries are due to the employees
themselves and what they're willing to
put up with and no secret that
government jobs are relatively chill and
while you can argue all you want about
how great a given company's culture is
it's simply not comparable to the
government it's truly a nine to five and
while the government does have its own
fair share of stressful jobs the vast
majority are not for example think about
a tax examiner at the IRS or a clerk at
the DMV this laid-back nature is one of
the biggest selling factors of the
public industry not to mention it the
job security but this also means that
everyone who ends up joining the public
industry isn't all that particular about
the pay they of course want to be paid a
livable wage but they rarely look for
more this means that they rarely ask for
wage increases or promotions and they're
definitely not a job hopping to maximize
pay this isn't stark contrast to the
Private Industry which has very much
trended it in the opposite direction
employee loyalty is at all time lows and
the days of people spending 40 or 50
years at the same company are long gone
the same however cannot be said about
the government it's not uncommon to see
government employees who have spent
decades if not their entire careers at
the government but while the government
has employed loyalty this simply leads
to less competitive salaries when your
employees are willing to stick around it
regardless of whether you keep up with
Market wages or inflation it's unlikely
that you actually keep up with Market
wages and inflation and the given that
most employees are complacent and
comfortable no one really does anything
about it now of course there are some
unions who fight for better pay and that
they definitely put forth the Valiant
effort but at the end of the day they're
really just fighting for peanuts for
example this Union is trying to increase
the 2023 pay raise from 4.6 percent to
5.1 percent I mean it they're literally
having to fight over half percent in the
Private Industry the tone is more like
if you're not willing to give me a
twenty thousand dollar promotion I'm
gonna switch to someone who is something
else to note is that a large number of
government employees that aren't even
there for the pay in the first place
virtually all government leaders are
there for popularity power and Prestige
not for a paycheck a similar argument
could be made for everyday employees as
well many of them were simply there for
the health insurance or the retirement
benefits these people usually have
spouses who work in the Private Industry
or they themselves work in the Private
Industry and saved up a bunch of money
before switching over so they don't
actually have to worry all that much
about saving for retirement or
maximizing their pay all they have to do
is pay their dues and to cash out the
benefits and that's exactly what they're
looking to do
foreign
much of the public sector can be
explained by complacency this isn't true
for everyone working at the government
unfortunately a non-negligible portion
of the public sector is filled with
people who don't exactly want to be
there this primarily consists of people
that the private sector views as
undesirable or unhirable this doesn't
necessarily mean that these employees
are bad employees per se but they have
trades that private companies that just
don't want to deal with for example a
given employee may have a long job gap
on their resume now this employee may
have a perfectly legitimate reason for
this Gap maybe they were taking care of
a sick relative or maybe they were sick
themselves but private companies that
don't really care about the reason from
their perspective this may be an
indication that no one wants to hire
this person also it's more than likely
that the person is Rusty at the job so
the company would rather just move on to
the next applicant than investigate
further another popular hurdle for many
applicants is a lack of networking you
would think that truly qualified
candidates would have no trouble finding
a job but this is not actually the case
especially during Market downturns in
fact it adds it way more valuable to
have an extensive Professional Network
than it just simply have the skills
given that the largest portion of hires
come from employee referrals from the
company's perspective it it makes way
more sense to bet on someone that a good
employee is willing to vouch for as
opposed to someone that you have to
judge based on a piece of paper and
finally the last major group of people
who have a difficult time of finding
private jobs is people with disabilities
while companies it may be willing to
accommodate for someone with a
wheelchair or Autism it's unlikely that
they'll deal with someone who is deaf or
blind now technically it is illegal for
employers to discriminate based on an
applicant's disabilities but if we're
being real here that's not exactly how
things play out also employers are
allowed to discriminate if they can
argue that a given disability will limit
an individual from completing a job
functions and that this isn't not that
hard of an argument to make when an
applicant is deaf or blind regardless of
the job the government on the other hand
isn't magnitudes more likely to give
such candidates a chance and oftentimes
they're the only ones to give such
candidates a chance so while these
people may not want to settle for lower
compensation at the government they
really have no choice and that they
don't have much negotiating power either
laughs
low government salaries are not new the
government has always paid less than the
Private Industry but they usually made
up for this with better work-life
balance and benefits over the past few
decades though the disparity between
private and government jobs has simply
grown larger and larger in the given the
record high inflation right now the
appeal of government jobs is not nearly
as clear you can argue that the
government offers greater job security
during a recession but at what cost
we're not talking about a salary
difference of fifty thousand at the
government versus seventy thousand in
the Private Industry we're talking more
like 50k at the government versus 100K
Plus in the Private Industry and the
government each promotion gets you an
extra few thousand dollars while the
promotion in the Private Industry
usually gets you tens of thousands of
dollars when you compound this reality
over an entire career we're talking
about lower compensation on the scale of
millions so if you're currently a broken
government job or are considering taking
one it may be time to reconsider your
options
but that's just what I think would you
take a government job comment that down
below also drop a like if you think that
government employees are underpaid and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community to just put your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions about how to answer until
then I'm party and I'll see you guys on
the next one